[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
nous sommes le lundi 29 mars voici les
titres de ce journal c'est la question
sur toutes les lèvres faut-il fermer les
écoles face à la troisième vague de kobe
19 28 classes ont été fermées
dernièrement dans les yvelines
le protocole sanitaire a été renforcée
par l'éducation nationale le syndicat
fsu 60,18 lui appel à la grève pour
dénoncer un protocole qui n'est pas en
accord avec la situation épidémique
invitait la députée des yvelines
béatrice piron et bertrand mesure qu'au
secrétaire du snuipp et pfs eu 78 briser
le tabou de l'incontinence l'objectif
d'une table ronde qui s'est récemment
tenue à rambouillet la réunit
professionnels et dans et personnes
confrontées à cette problématique qui
toucherait 8% de la population française
c'était à l'initiative de la start up
qui vit noise noé et en présence de la
députée aurore bergé
enfin reportage auprès de l'association
pour la promotion de la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines face à
l'impossibilité de se produire en public
elle s'adapte la pm est ce qu a
enregistré son traditionnel concert de
musique classique destiné aux élèves de
l'agglomération rencontre tout à l'heure
également avec les collégiens de paul
bert à chatou qui ont travaillé sur la
question du petit déjeuner équilibré
[Musique]
semaine décisive sur la question du coc
vide 19 le pic de la deuxième vague de
l'épidémie est quasiment atteint il y
aura-t-il un nouveau tour de vis des
mesures actuelles
alors que les yvelines tout comme l'île
de france sont placés sous la mesure du
confinement depuis plus d'une semaine
rien n'est décidé a affirmé emmanuel
macron dans les cônes les colonnes du
journal du dimanche il pourrait prendre
la parole le président de la république
ce mercredi soir toujours dans le jdd
une quarantaine de directeurs médicaux
de crise de l'ap-hp est dit dans une
tribune se préparer à devoir faire un
tri des patients et s'attend à un manque
critique de lits dans les 15 prochains
jours dans la région est la troisième
vague de kovy 19 s'intensifie dans la
région et le département si on regarde
ces derniers chiffres collectés sur une
semaine le taux d'incidence le nombre de
nouveaux contaminée pour 100000
habitants a fortement augmenté + 89 il
s'établit désormais à 550 le taux de
tests positifs est également en légère
hausse à l'hôpital la tension devient
encore plus fortes et des lits de
réanimation occupé à 127 7 % en
ile-de-france 550 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier dimanche sur le
territoire des yvelines 80 en
réanimation est depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire nil 507 personnes sont
décédées du colis de 19 dans les
hôpitaux yvelinois dans ce contexte la
question de la fermeture des écoles et
notamment évoqué comme un dernier
recours par le gouvernement l'éducation
nationale et vient de renforcer en tout
cas son protocole sanitaire dans les
départements au confinement fermeture
d'une classe désormais des quinquas
positif est avérée depuis trois semaines
des tests salivaires sont également
effectués dans les écoles yvelinoise
exemple à rambouillet avec célia gars de
son go et marine de la barbe et tu
prépares plein de fait les plaintes à
gauche ok quand on a un fétu crash dans
le pâté tu laisses qu'on est un fan et
venant d'un flacon toute la matinée ce
sont 184 élèves volontaires sur 224 qui
ont effectué des tests salivaires dans
cette école élémentaire clerbois à
rambouillet suite à l'apparition de cas
dans les écoles maternelles la mairie et
l'éducation nationale ont demandé de
faire des tests dans les quatre écoles
du quartier
je pense que ces tests salivaires arrive
à point parce que dans notre école
il ya une enseignante donc bac a été
testée positive hier
et puis vu qu'il ya eu des cas et
notamment à une dans l'une des écoles
maternelles à côté voilà ça peut aussi
faire importe c'est une sécurité en plus
et puis pour un test qui est qui est
somme toute pas invasif c'est encore une
fois c'est du temps pris sur les
apprentissages mais c'est un moindre mal
par rapport à la situation
le test est simple il suffit de cracher
dans un petit bocal
il sera ensuite envoyés en laboratoire
les résultats arrivent en 24 heures un
test beaucoup plus appréciés par les
enfants font saliver dans un bocal et
c'est pas du tout des engendre des
agrafes comparant aux tests pcr
c'est pour faire avancer un peu les
choses et surtout pour savoir si on doit
fermer les écoles moments comme ça je
peux côté gm à manille qui aime qui est
pas très en forme et ça permet de voir
si les corps y vont pas les enseignants
en contact permanent avec les élèves ont
eux aussi fait le test même si on
applique évidemment les gestes barrière
dans l'école on est quand même avec eux
tout le temps et c'est important de se
faire tester de savoir qui dans l'école
est positif ou pas résultat deux cas
positifs ont été détectés dans deux
classes différentes ce qui entraîne
directement leur fermeture puisque le
nouveau protocole sanitaire mise en
place par jean michel blanquer
dès ce lundi 29 mars prévoit la
fermeture d'une classe entière lorsqu'un
seul cas de kobe 19 est détectée dans
les dix-neuf départements confiné et
d'après les derniers chiffres de
l'éducation nationale 28 classes ont été
fermées ces derniers jours dans les
yvelines un collège est des données
arrêtées au jeudi 25 mars 13 heures et
qui ne prennent donc pas en compte est
le renforcement du protocole sanitaire
on apprend par exemple ce lundi à que
toutes les classes de l'école maternelle
de la grande île à voisins le bretonneux
sont fermés à tout comme une classe de
cp cm1 à l'élémentaire de la grande île
toujours à voisins le bretonneux aussi
une école maternelle a également fermé
ses portes pour une semaine à
rosny-sur-seine alors faut-il fermer
plus généralement les écoles comme on
l'a vu lors du premier confinement je
vais poser la question à mes deux
invités tout d'abord en plateau bertrand
mesure bonsoir à co secrétaire
départemental du snuipp et 78 fait sur
78 c'est le syndicat d'enseignants du
premier degré il ya d'ailleurs un appel
à la grève qui a été lancé par le ffs eu
dès aujourd'hui pour dénoncer je cite un
gouffre entre la situation épidémique et
le protocole sanitaire dans les écoles
c'est un mouvement qui débute jusqu'aux
vacances c'est ça voilà c'était quelque
chose que nous avons lancé pour
permettre aux collègues de se mobiliser
dans une situation de crise que le
ministre ne veut pas entendre et qu'ils
continuent à nier et est ce que c est
suivie dès aujourd'hui se voir écouter
c'est un peu tôt pour le dire voilà
c'est le début de toute façon les écoles
sont maintenant très désorganisé les
lycées les collèges aussi et je crois
que la première chose qu'il faut faire
c'est arrêter de mentir aux français et
de leur faire croire que l'école peut
continuer comme elle continue
actuellement ça n'est plus possible ce
ministre est dans le déni c'est une
faillite intellectuelle et morale et il
ya un moment où il faut pouvoir le dire
et c'est pour ça c'est le sens de ce
mouvement de grève avec toi également en
visioconférence béatrice piron bonsoir
bonsoir mais député la république en
marge de la 3ème circonscription des
yvelines l'exécutif a dit que la
fermeture des écoles serait un dernier
recours pour le moment ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour et en croire un clip
partagé par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale sur son compte twitter qui
milite pour des cours en présentiel
on se dit que ça va pas forcément
arriver dans les prochains jours et
béatrice piron est ce que le
renforcement du protocole sanitaire dans
les écoles on rappelle depuis vendredi
et dès qu'un cas positifs de coronavirus
et est avérée dans une classe et bien
cette classe est fermée systématiquement
est-ce que d'après vous c'est l'ultime
recours pour éviter justement la
fermeture mais je pense que le protocole
ce nouveau protocole sanitaire est
encore un moyen d'encore mieux adapter
la situation à chaque à chaque école
effectivement il permettra de briser les
chefs de contamination vécurent en aucun
cas positif dans une classe mais que
l'objectif que beaucoup de parents et
que l'éducation nationale défend et de
dire qu il était important de laisser
l'école ouverte le plus longtemps
possible et ça serait vraiment dommage
ou dommageable pour les enfants d'avoir
des écoles fermées dans des villes où il
ya aucun cas il ya des villes en france
où il n'y a aucun cas de covile il ya
des écoles où il ya aucun élève et même
dans les yvelines où nous sommes
maintenant
rouge la répartition des cas est
relativement concentrés demain n'est pas
homogène du tout sûr dans les villes
donc il ya des villes relativement plus
être un peu d'autres donc effectivement
il ya des écoles qui ont fermé il ya des
classes les enfermer il ya des collèges
qui sont fermés moi j'avais un chèque de
3 collèges fermés dans les yvelines donc
qui est peut-être important sur
certaines villes mais dans d'autres
élèves et l'autre classe dans d'autres
villes et notamment sur ma
circonscription j'ai sondé mois au
niveau des établissements des collèges
de ma circonscription il ya très très
peu de cas et voir aucun cas dans
certains collèges
donc il serait dommage de priver les
élèves d'une éducation
là on peut alors leur rendre ce week-end
l'unesco à se mobiliser justement pour
dire que mondialement 20% des élèves
d'une classe d'âge avaient été privés
l'instruction cette année la france fait
partie des pays où on est riche et le
plus ouvert possible et je crois qu'il
faut en être fier sur ce protocole
renforcement du protocole sanitaire
bertrand mesurer ce que c'est une bonne
mesure fallait-il aller encore tout le
monde le constat que l'on fait depuis le
marque mars de l'année dernière c'est
qu' aucun des protocoles n'est
applicable
donc on peut toujours mettre en place
tous les protocoles que l'on veut le
constat empirique que l'on fait
actuellement c'est qu' aucun des
protocoles n'a permis d'enrayer lampitt
l'épidémie quand elle se cantonne se
développe vous êtes encore plus grand du
coup ferme et peut-être les écoles je
pense que par exemple vous évoquiez le
clip que jean michel blanquer a dit sur
son compte twitter il faut savoir que
c'est un clip qui vient des états unis
et que le professeur qu'il a fait et
sachant ce que jean michel blanquer on
avait fait s'est empressé de dire que
aux états unis tous les enseignants eux
avaient été vaccinés et que donc de fait
il était beaucoup plus facile de
continuer à laisser les écoles ouverts
mais monsieur blanc caire ne s'est donné
aucun moyen c'est à dire que cette année
ils ressentent
il rend 200 millions d'euros au budget
de l'éducation nationale alors que nous
avons une crise pour les masques alors
que nous n'avons pas de tests salivaires
en nombre suffisant alors que nous ne
sommes pas vacciner alors que partout il
ya un constat de carence qui est fait
aussi bien ce qui concerne l'entretien
des bâtiments que le matériel nécessaire
à une bonne des infections n'ont
manifestement
monsieur blanc caire n'est pas à la
hauteur de la situation emmanuel macron
pourrait s'exprimer ce mercredi soir
cela n'a pas été encore confirmée par
l'exécutif
est-ce que la situation est encore
tenable béatrice piron celle de
maintenir les écoles ouvertes finalement
il n'y a pas de risque avec ce nouveau
protocole que les classes se ferme par
elle même que les écoles se ferme par
elle-même je le pense pareil je les vois
sur le terrain dans les écoles des
discours d'enseignants qui sont
totalement différent du discours que
tient ce monsieur donc il est le point
de vue d'un syndicat mais bon ce n'est
aujourd'hui par exemple à part mis dans
ma circonscription j'ai aucun enseignant
qui soient en grève et quand je les
écoute pour eux le protocole est bien
respectée dans leur école le protocole
est respectée le fait de fermer glace
dès qu'il ya un cas positif je ne pense
pas que ce soit quelque chose qui soit
impossible à respecter je pense que ça
sera très très vite appliqué les parents
sont capables de le comprendre de
s'adapter et aujourd'hui donc je pense
qu'il vaut mieux faire du sur mesure
suivant chaque situation
plutôt que de priver les enfants de
scolarisation d'autant plus qu'on arrive
sur une période aujourd'hui des belles
journées
si les enfants sont pas scolarisés et
que les parents continuent travail
histoire télétravail soit parfois sur
leur lieu de travail
on va avoir des enfants dans la rue qui
vont être livrés à eux même plus parler
la poudre en place mais en plus de ça
ils vont se contaminer entre eux parce
qu'ils vont aller les uns chez deshors
sans respecter aucun geste sans
respecter aucun protocole puisque là il
y aura peut-être plus d'adultes pour les
surveiller être avec eux je pense
qu'hier on a déjà constaté que pendant
les vacances scolaires des fois le taux
de contamination des enfants réaugmenter
parce que s'il serait ou c'est entre eux
je pense qu'il ya moins de risque en les
laissant à l'époque peut aller s'ils
sont pas déjà voté limiers corps et les
amarres
dernière chose qu'on arrive déjà à la
fin de cet entretien les solutions
justement pour maintenir les classes
ouvertes
on a parlé énormément de la vaccination
des enseignants dernièrement bertrand
mesure qui est promise par le
gouvernement dès la mi-avril
vous parlez aussi la campagne de tests
salivaires qui à votre sens n'est pas
encore assez développé
les ridicules si on prend par exemple la
situation des yvelines ça représente
7500 test salivaire pour les yvelines
qui doit se polariser à peu près 250
mille élèves en plus de leurs profits
avec leurs professeurs c'est absolument
ridicule quand on voit qu'on d'autriche
les parents la possibilité de tester
chez eux avec des tests salivaires qui
sont distribués dans les écoles deux
fois par semaine là il s'agit d'une
mesurette qui permet à jean michel
blanquer de faire croire qu'il se fait
quelque chose pour tester les personnels
et les enfants alors que ça n'est
absolument pas le cas
la vaccination des enseignants la
vaccination des enseignants c'est pareil
la vaccination des enseignants elle aura
au mieux lieu jean-paul je suis prêt à
prendre le pari au mois de juin c'est à
dire bien trop tard pour la fin de
l'année on termine avec vous béatrice
pur ans sont deux solutions
l'intensification peut-être des tests
salivaires dans les écoles et la mise en
place de cette campagne de vaccination
pour les enseignants
l'exécutif la premier td des mises dès
mi-avril même si bertrand mesure dit que
ce n'est pas forcément plus deux
millions quatre de doses qui a rythmé
avril réservé pour les enseignants je
pense que les enseignants seront
rapidement vaccinés surtout tous les
volontaires et je vois pas pourquoi on
serait négative à la voir jusqu'à
présent on a respecté notre plan à
quelques pourcentages très de
vaccination on avait dit qu'on sait aux
alentours de 10 millions
miami je pense qu on est très proche il
connaît déjà un humiliant et
qu'aujourd'hui le rythme les aime bien
bien plus rapide qu'au début
donc moi j'ai positive sur steam east et
je crois qu on fait des tests salivaires
n'en faisais pas il ya quelques mois et
se tasser un peu plus peut-être plus
d'ici quelques semaines - or pourra
faire de notre test à domicile le plus
on fait de test mieux c'est je suis
d'accord mais si aujourd'hui on détecte
à peu près une centaine de cas d'enfants
dont ils sont positifs tous les jours
dans les yvelines
c'est bien parce qu'on fait des tests
sinon les détecterait pas il
moins d'un pour cent des élèves testés
donc c'est pas quand même lui contagion
très très importante
merci à vous d'être venu en parlant
plateau béatrice piron par
visioconférence député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines et merci à
à bertrand mesure a qu'au secrétaire du
snuipp fsu soixante dix huit sur cette
question de la fermeture ou non à
déclasser des écoles 1 nous devrions en
savoir plus cette semaine je vous disais
manuel macron pourrait prendre la parole
mercredi soir l'information n'a pas
encore été confirmée comprendre
l'importance d'un petit déjeuner
équilibré et éco-responsable au collège
paul bert de chatou des élèves ont
participé vendredi dernier un parcours
éducatif de santé ils ont d'abord pris
un petit déjeuner complet et on finit
par faire des exercices physiques avec
la caravane santé de l'urss versailles
le reportage dasri bergère un petit
déjeuner sain un corps sain et une
planète saine vendredi 26 mars des
élèves de 5e du collège paul bert de
chatou ont participé à un parcours
éducatif de santé qui allie plusieurs
disciplines
l'anglais les svt la physique-chimie et
le sport et la matinée a commencé par un
petit déjeuner équilibré
aujourd'hui j'ai pris un peu de chocolat
un kiwi bio du jus de pomme bio de la
pâte à tartiner bio avec des crêpes
les crêpes aussi à son bios et du lait
au chocolat chaque élève a pu composer
son petit déjeuner pour avoir un aliment
il fallait le demander en anglais et les
collégiens ont bien compris qu'on
pouvait se faire plaisir en mangeant
équilibré et en respectant la planète
là je trouve que c'est bien comme ça ça
nous apprend à bien manger et à prendre
le temps de bien choisir ses aliments et
de bien manger parce que c'est important
pour la santé
la rectrice de l'académie de versailles
a rencontré les collégiens ils ont
présenté des expériences de physique
chimie et ont fait goûter une pâte à
tartiner maison la matinée s'est conclue
par du sport ont fait faire un parcours
qui a été construit avec des médecins
dans une salle de sport donc il ya des
tests de force des tests d'endurance des
tests respiratoires et cela permet de
faire prendre conscience aux jeunes de
l'importance de toutes ces données
ces exercices de sport permettent entre
autres de repérer les élèves en
difficulté surtout les tests que nous
avons fait est à peu près 25% de jeunes
qui ont besoin de redynamiser leurs
activités de santé et pour lesquels il
faut qu'on fasse le lien avec
l'infirmière
l'enseignant de ps qui va pouvoir
apporter des réponses plus personnalisé
aux résultats de ces tests
la caravane santé de l'ue nss versailles
a été lancée à la rentrée 2020 et a déjà
touché 5000 élèves dans l'académie dans
l'actualité également le coup de massue
pour le secteur du tourisme en ile de
france en 2020 le territoire francilien
a perdu 33,1 millions de visiteurs par
rapport à l'année précédente ce qui
représente une perte de 15,5 milliards
d'euros en un an une chute libre révélée
aujourd'hui par le comité régional du
tourisme
conséquence directe de la crise
sanitaire l'an passé plus de 17 millions
de touristes dont plus de 70% de
français sont venus dans la région le
recul s'est ressenti à tous les niveaux
et nuitées hôtelières fréquentation des
monuments et musées ainsi que sur le
tourisme d'affaires
la mobilisation des conducteurs du
réseau stibus les syndicats cgt unsa des
cars périer qui exploite 60 % du réseau
ont déposé deux préavis de grève
mouvement déclenché suite à l'échec des
négociations annuelles obligatoires les
syndicats demandent notamment une hausse
salariale 1 5% pour l'unsa 2,5 pour cent
pour la cgt une prime qu'ovide est des
demandes non acceptée par la direction
qui était prête à prévoir une
augmentation de 0 5% est la greffe est
donc déclenché les préavis court
jusqu'au 31 décembre si les
revendications ne sont pas entendues et
les syndicats annoncent que le mouvement
est suivi par 87 % des conducteurs du
réseau ski bus confirmé en revanche
aujourd'hui une dizaine de lignes
circulaient normalement ce lundi elle
rester informé sur le site qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran ski bus point fr en
france à 8 % de la population
souffrirait d'incontinence face à ce
constat et au manque d'accompagnement à
la start-up évinoise noé a décidé
d'organiser une table ronde sur le sujet
l'événement s'est déroulée à la
résidence les jardins de l'arcadie à
rambouillet c'était vendredi dernier les
précisons les précisions dans ce sujet
de justin braz et une table ronde pour
briser le tabou de l'incontinence à
l'origine de l'événement la start-up noé
a réuni la députée aurore bergé des
professionnels des aidants et des
personnes confrontées à ce mal objectif
récolter des témoignages pour en
apprendre davantage et trouver des
solutions
je vous parlerai de l'asie
sein des entreprises julian qui est en
séduisant démoli handicap
on a eu des témoignages aujourd'hui qui
sont bouleversants d'une maman d'un
enfant polyhandicapé de 10 ans dont on
voit les douleurs au quotidien les
difficultés une fille d'une maman de 93
ans qu'il accompagne au quotidien et
puis toutes les personnes aides
soignantes auxiliaires de vie infirmière
qui évidemment accompagne et
interviennent donc non seulement ça
concerne beaucoup de personnes mais on
parle vraiment de la dignité humaine
en france 11 millions d'aidants sont
concernés pour leurs proches ils font
face à un manque d'information
d'une part pour nous les aidants mais de
façon générale le grand public et pas du
tout formation du personnel que ce soit
en hôpital
que ce soit au niveau des auxiliaires de
vie à domicile pourtant si ce mal reste
encore tabou aujourd'hui une
incontinence m'accompagner peut
engendrer de nombreux problèmes
il ya de l'isolément social il ya des
risques de chutes à domicile il ya des
pertes financières
il ya des risques de retour aux urgences
également dans les hôpitaux
donc il faut prendre ce sujet très au
sérieux la start-up nos essais donc
spécialisée dans l'accompagnement
personnalisé des personnes incontinentes
à domicile plusieurs solutions ont été
développées
on va leur rendre visite à domicile nous
allons créer un lien social et nous
allons calculer leur calendrier
mictionnels pour définir quels types de
protections pour la jours et pour la
nuit seront adaptées à leur cas
particulier
la start up sortira prochainement une
application mobile pour mieux
accompagner les patients est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter
clap de fin pour le sidaction 2021
l'événement de lutte contre le sida qui
se tenait ce week-end en france
cent soixante et onze mille personnes
vivent avec le vih en plein contexte de
crise sanitaire le bilan est bon près de
4,5 millions d'euros de promesses de
dons pour cette édition chiffre proche
du record de 2019 qui avait dépassé les
4 5 millions et même si le sidaction et
terminait les dons restent possibles par
téléphone jusqu'au 7 avril c'est au 110
toute l'année les dons peuvent se faire
également via le www.sidaction.org ou
par sms envoyés dont 92 110 pour donner
5 euros un mode de culture avant de vous
laisser l'association pour la promotion
de la musique à saint quentin en
yvelines s'adapte avec la crise
sanitaire
elle a enregistré en vidéo son
traditionnel concert de musique
classique destiné aux élèves de
l'agglomération eléonore si nokia et
matteo luxe euros
[Rires]
[Musique]
devant l'impossibilité de renouveler ses
concerts avec public l'association pour
la promotion de la musique à saint
quentin en yvelines à trouver une
solution au lieu d'accueillir près de
4000 enfants des écoles de
l'agglomération
elle a enregistré le concert en vidéo
les 25 et 26 mars dernier cette année le
kobe nous interdit d'avoir les enfants
et les personnes dans la salle donc on
fait l'un vers ce tir condamné l'
orchestre dans les familles et dans les
écoles qu'on pourrait dire avec un peu
d'humour que avant le faisaient plutôt
façon théâtre et là on le fait plutôt
façon cinéma
objectif faire découvrir la musique
classique dès le plus jeune âge à des
élèves qui n'ont pas forcément la
possibilité d'en écouter et pour peut
être aussi susciter des vocations
la barrière qui empêche les enfants de
pères de la musique classique on pense
qu'elle est financière et n'est pas
financière et la culture elle est donc
c'est tout l'objet de la paix mais ce qu
de porter la culture dans les milieux où
elle a de la peine à arriver
une quarantaine de musiciens de
l'ensemble instrumental de lavilledieu
étaient donc présents pour cette
captation vidéo au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et au
conservatoire de trappes cette année ils
ont joué le concerto pour piano d'edvard
grieg un grand compositeur norvégien
déjà la partie de piano et très théâtral
comme vous verrez très virtuose
l'orchestré un orchestre au grand
complet avec des vents des bois des
cuivres percussions cordes et c'est une
oeuvre qui s'enracine dans les mélodies
populaires et les mollets lee populaire
parle aux enfants
la vidéo du concert sera mise en ligne
prochainement sur le site internet de la
paix m excuse
l'association va également contacté les
enseignants de saint quentin en yvelines
pour la diffuser au maximum auprès des
plus jeunes
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant
l'actualité sportive dans le département
c'est dans le cetud sport présentée par
michael almy doro belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]